dimanche matin étant de la minière plus
de 130 personnes se sont inscrites au
départ de la septième run and bike de
guyancourt
une course qui mêle cyclisme et course à
pied en duo quelques minutes avant le
départ les participants étaient pleins
d'enthousiasmé à fond et puis ralentir
sur la fin parce que je crois qu'à une
côte pour finir donc ça risque d'être un
peu compliqué donc regarder un petit peu
pour la faire partir très rapidement dès
le départ on va continuer très
rapidement tout le long on peut on doit
pas être trop mal je pense croisés
notamment au programme de cette course
15 km avec deux montées sur des chemins
forestiers en terre ou en bitume pour
terminer la course il faut donc coopérer
sur le parcours la bonne stratégie c'est
de changer assez souvent comme ça le
coureur à pied fait un espèce de
fractionner il est le plus souvent à
pleine vitesse
et quand ils fatiguent il prend le vélo
pour se reposer puisque le vélo à quand
on est sur le vélo on est beaucoup moins
sur les sites et physiquement la course
a finalement été remporté par maxime st
martin et antoine la snrt du triathlon
club saint quentin en yvelines en 48
minutes et 4 secondes duo a devancé de
près de 4 minutes ses adversaires ouais
c'était dur l aco s'appliquer les gens
allaient à la côte à la fema de france
du coup on en a su réguler antoine et
comme il est meilleur comme en vélo il a
fait la côte à vélo et les parties
devant et après il m'a passé le relais
et on a on a bien joué là dessus du coup
ces mécontents rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une huitième édition
autour des étangs de la minière